A GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARING.
.
I'M CALLING THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER F
LIKE TO THINK WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE FIRST HEARING OF THE YEAR
I'D ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME MISTER
JONES SAWYER WHO IS SITTING IN
FOR MR MCCARTY TODAY.
AND.
.
THE MISTRUST CAR WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE YOU'LL BE SITTING ON
ALL YEAR FOR YOURSELF.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
HERE.
ALRIGHT.
AND THE.
SO YOU'RE HERE.
MANY.
YOU.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
ACCORDING HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU. NOW WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON FILE TODAY BUT ONE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE MISTER
CARLY HAS BEEN PULLED LEAVING TO
TO BE HEARD TODAY THEY ARE. AB
SEVEN SIX ONE.
AND AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT I
BELIEVE MUST DOCTOR WEBER WILL
PERCENT THAT BECAUSE MR GLORIOUS
NOT PRESENT TODAY.
WE ARE NOW READY FOR OUR FIRST
AUTHOR JUST REMEMBER COMMITTEE
RULES ARE TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
RIGHT AFTER THE AUTHOR PRESENTS.
YOU ARE GOING TO PRESENT I DON'T
SEE MR MULLIN.
PRESIDENT.
AND SO A DOCTOR WELL OVER SAID
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT.
MR GLORIA IS NOT WITH US TODAY.
THERE AND AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TODD GLORIA WHO
COULD NOT BE WITH US WE ASK ME
TO PRESENT TO YOU HIS BILL AB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT.
ALL THIS BILL AIMS TO ENHANCE
THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS BY PROTECTING THE RIGHTS
OF STUDENTS TO WEAR CULTURAL
AND.
CULTURAL ADORNMENTS AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES
UNDER EXISTING LAW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE PERMITTED TO
DEVELOP REASONABLE DRESS CODE
POLICIES THAT FOSTER A POSITIVE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. AND
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ONLY UNJUSTLY
ENFORCED THEIR DRESS CODE
POLICIES TO PROHIBIT STUDENTS
FROM WEARING APPROPRIATE
CULTURAL DORMANT AT GRADUATION.
THESE INCIDENTS REVEAL THE
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE BEING PREVENTED FROM
RECOGNIZING THEIR CULTURAL
TRADITION WELL CELEBRATING A
PERSONAL MILESTONE.
FOR ALL STUDENTS BUT FOR ALL
STUDENTS BUT FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION IS A
SIGNIFICANT OCCASION.
AMONG AMERICAN INDIANS AND
ALASKA NATIVE STUDENTS A HIGH%
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE IS SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT. THE LOWEST OF ANY
RACIAL ETHNIC DEMOGRAPHICS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
REGRETTABLY THIS PROBLEM IS NOT
UNIQUE TO NATIVE AMERICANS IN IN
NEARBY ELK GROVE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENT WAS ESCORTED
OUT OF THE SCHOOLS GRADUATION
VENUE. AFTER REFUSING TO REMOVE
A KENTE CLOTH.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
BELLWETHER FLAYED INCLUSIVITY.
BY PROTECTING A PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO WEAR CULTURAL DORM AT
CEREMONIES AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
PROTECTS OUR STUDENTS RIGHTS TO
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION.
THIS BILL MAY SOUND FAMILIAR.
THIS COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE LAST YEAR. UNFORTUNATELY
THE GOVERNOR VETOED AB TWO
THIRTY THREE CITING THE BELIEVE
THAT SCHOOL ELECTED SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE BEST POSITIONED TO
MAKE JUDGMENTS ABOUT GRADUATION
WITH A TIRE UP UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE AUTHORS HOPING TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO DISCUSS A
POTENTIAL COMPROMISE WILL MAKE
CLEAR STUDENTS RIGHTS TO WEAR
CULTURAL DORMA GRADUATION
WITHOUT ELIMINATING OR REDUCING
LOCAL CONTROL. I HAVE A WE HAVE
ONE WITNESS YOU TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT IS AN
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION OF THE
RIGHTS OF STUDENTS TO WEAR
RELIGIOUS CEREMONY OR CULTURAL
ADORNMENTS THAT SCHOOL
GRADUATION CEREMONIES.
THE SEMINAL U. S. SUPREME COURT
CASE OF TINKER VERSUS TO MOINS
INVOLVED EXPRESSION BY THE
WEARING OF AN ITEM IN THAT CASE
BLACK ARMBANDS TO PROTEST THE
VIETNAM WAR. THE SUPREME COURT
HELD THAT STUDENTS RIGHT TO
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION ALLOW THIS
TYPE OF PROTEST SO LONG AS IT
DID NOT DISRUPT THE OPERATION OF
THE SCHOOL. THIS TYPE OF
EXPRESSION IS ALSO PROTECTED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
STUDENTS SHOULD EQUALLY BE ABLE
TO WEAR ADORNMENTS AS AN
EXPRESSION OF THEIR RELIGIOUS OR
CULTURAL HERITAGE HERITAGE AGAIN
AS THE BILL MAKES CLEAR SO LONG
AS DOING SO IS NOT DISRUPTIVE.
BY CLARIFYING THE LAW AB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT WILL PROTECT
STUDENTS RIGHTS AND OFFER
GUIDANCE TO SCHOOL DISTRICT SO
IT'S TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION.
AS ANYONE WHO HAS ATTENDED A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION CEREMONY
KNOWS IT IS A JOYFUL AN
IMPORTANT CEREMONY FOR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. IS A TIME
FOR CELEBRATION NOT ONLY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AND WHAT HE
OR SHE HAS ACCOMPLISHED. BUT
ALSO OF EVERYONE WHO HELPED GET
THE STUDENT TO THAT POINT
THE FAMILY AND THE HERITAGE OF
THE STUDENT. IT IS ALSO THE
MARKING OF AN IMPORTANT
TRANSITION.
STUDENTS WHO ARE MARKING THAT
TRANSITION SHOULD CONSISTENT
THERE COULD CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS BE ABLE TO WEAR THE
ADORNMENTS THAT THEIR CULTURES
USE ON SUCH OCCASIONS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWELVE
FORTY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NO WITNESSES OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SHERRI MCCUE REPRESENT PECHANGA
PANEL THE SAME YOU INDIANS AND
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
I THINK SUPPORTS COME UP THE
MICROPHONE REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SPORT.
KITTY BORROW WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF
THE YOU SEE ANY IN AS BAND OF
CHUMASH INDIANS AND THE STOCK
ONE TRIBE IN SUPPORT.
SEC BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION YET WE
DID SUPPORT LAST YEAR'S VERSION
I'LL BE. MOVING A SUPPORT
POSITION FORWARD THIS YEAR OUR
STRENGTH IS IN OUR DIVERSITY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YEAH I KNOW I'VE SEEN
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU PAM LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE RINCON A TRIBE OF LOUIS
SENIOR INDIANS IN THE TO THE
RIVER TRIBE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NANCY TRIED ASSISTING ALSO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND REGRETTABLY WE
DO HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IT'S
AN ODD SITUATION IN WHICH WE
AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
APPROACH THAT THIS BILL. TAKES
CROPS A MUCH LARGER.
EXCEPTION THEN.
THE THE THEN ACTUALLY SEEMS TO
BE THE AIM OF THE PROPONENTS ARE
REGRETTABLY WE HAVE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SINGLE
MOTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
BILLS WERE MOVED AND SECONDED.
YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER OF
TODD GLORIA.
WE HAVE A MOTION UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS.
ALONG WITH THEM AGAIN OUR
MOTION.
DID I DO PASSED TO A JUDICIARY
IS THE MOTION.
O'DONNELL BY DONALD.
I THOUGHT IT.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
THURMAN. WEBER AYE WEBER AYE.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX VOTES.
IRAQ COULD YOU CHAIR.
LOW'S PRESENTERS.
YEAH HERE.
HOW ARE GOING TO SEE?
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN COME OUT.
SO YOU PLEASE PRESENT AB SEVEN
SIX ONE. GREATER THANK YOU ARE
MISTER CHAIR I GUESS WE'RE
HAVING TWINS TAKES YOU TWICE AS
LONG TO GET HER I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WITH THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE PURPOSE
OF A STRONG PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS TO CULTIVATE AN
INFORMED ELECTORATE CAPABLE OF
ENGAGING WITH GOVERNMENT.
WE ALL GREW BACK CONSIDERING THE
TUMULTUOUS TIMES WE LIVE IN IT
IS NOW MORE IMPORTANT EVER. THAT
WE MUST ENDOW OUR STUDENTS WITH
A PROPENSITY TOWARD CIVIC
EDUCATION.
AB SEVEN SIX ONE AUTHOR
AUTHORIZES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP HISTORY
SOCIAL SCIENCE IN CIVICS TASK
ASSIGNMENTS
WE'RE GRADES FOUR EIGHT. AND
ONCE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
I HAVE HERE TODAY SU LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
RESEARCH AND POLICY ASSOCIATION
A A RESEARCH AND POLICY
ASSOCIATE.
ASSOCIATE WITH THE ARE LEARNING.
POLICY INSTITUTE AND CARRY
CASUALLY DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
WITH A CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO THEM. MISSING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURVEYING ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD
LOOKS AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
A AB SOME SIXTY ONE WOULD ADD
HIS USUAL FOR SCIENCE
PERFORMANCE TASK ASSESSMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ASSESSMENT SYSTEM.
A PERFORMANCE TEST ASSESSMENTS
WHICH FOCUS ON ON CIVICS
EDUCATION AS WELL AS CRITICAL
THINKING ANALYTICAL AND RESEARCH
SKILLS.
AT THE PERFORMANCE TAX
ASSESSMENTS WOULD BE OPTIONAL TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO LOCALLY
ADMINISTER R. SCORE AND
MAINTAIN.
THE BILL PERMITS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL MATERIALS
TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS SUCH EYES
ADMINISTRATION GUIDES AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
DEVELOPMENT.
I'M IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE STATE
USHERED IN. A NEW AS A PARA OF
STUDENT TESTING BY IMPLEMENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENTS FOR
PROGRESS IN PERFORMANCE ALSO
KNOWN AS THOMAS.
THE CASTE SYSTEM WAS A IS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS TO
IMPROVE TEACHING AND LEARNING
SIMILARLY AB SAM SIMON.
STILL ONE WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS.
RESOURCE IS JUST TO SUPPORT.
AND IMPROVE TEACHING AND
LEARNING FOR HIS TO SOCIAL
SCIENCE.
.
THE SIZE OF OUR STATE IN OUR
NATION DEPENDS ON EDUCATED
INFORMED AND ACTIVE CITIZENS AND
RESIDENTS. AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE
WOULD HELP ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATION SYSTEM PREPARES OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH SPECIFIC
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND VALUES TO
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE CAREER AND
SENATE LIFE. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS MEASURE I HAVE WITH ME
CARRIED ASHLEY DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANNA MER ON
BEHALF OF THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE.
IF YOU TAKE A DRIVING TEST YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED A PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT INACTION.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
MULTIPLE CHOICE WRITTEN EXAM BUT
THE MOMENT WHEN THE INSTRUCTOR
GETS YOUR CAR. AND YOU HAVE TO
SHOW THAT YOU KNOW HOW TO
PARALLEL PARK.
SIMILARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
SOCIAL SCIENCE HISTORY AND
CIVICS.
IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO CONFUSE
THE BASIC KNOWLEDGE THAT HE
ASSESSED BY A STANDARDIZED TEST.
WITH THE DEEPER LEARNING THAT
CAN BE ASSESSED BY PERFORMANCE
TASKS.
THESE TASKS RANGE FROM ESSAYS
AND OPEN ENDED PROBLEMS ON
WRITTEN TESTS.
THE CLASSROOM COMMUNITY BASED
PROJECTS WHERE STUDENTS
DEMONSTRATE SKILLS
SUCH AS RESEARCH COLLABORATION
AND CRITICAL THINKING.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT STUDENTS WHO
EXPERIENCE INQUIRY PROJECTS
LINKED TO PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT.
PERFORMED BETTER ON MEASURES OF
HIGHER ORDER SKILLS LIKE
ANALYSIS OR EVALUATION.
AS WELL AS UNTRADITIONAL
STANDARDIZED TESTS.
AND THIS APPROACH IS HAPPENING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
A NEW LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
REPORT FINDS THAT AT LEAST
SEVENTEEN STATES CURRENTLY
ENCOURAGE OR REQUIRE THE USE OF
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT.
IN WASHINGTON STATE TEACHERS
WORK WITH THE STATE TO DEVELOP
SOCIAL SCIENCE PERFORMANCE TASK.
ELEVENTH GRADERS
WRITE AN ESSAY IN WHICH THE
STATE A POSITION ON A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE THAT
pINDIVIDUAL RIGHTS AND THE
COMMON
GOOD. CITING A COURT CASE OR
GOVERNMENT POLICY.
THE STATE HAS DEVELOPED AN
ONLINE RESOURCE BANK THAT
INCLUDE STANDARDS LIKE TASKS
RUBRICS AND SCORING GUIDES AND
TEACHERS ENGAGE IN LOCAL SCORING
OF STUDENT WORK.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA A NETWORK OF
MORE THAN FORTY SCHOOLS INTENDED
STRIX CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
COLLABORATIVE. USE TEACHER
DEVELOPED FORM PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS TO MEASURE STUDENT
LEARNING.
IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALL TWELFTH GRADERS
ENGAGE OF RIGOROUS RESEARCH BASE
CAPSTONE PROJECTS%
OFTEN WITH THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
COMPONENT.
ALUMNI REPORT FEELING BETTER
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE AND
TEACHERS ALSO LEARN FROM THE
PROCESS.
THESE EXAMPLES SHOW THE
POSSIBILITY FOR EDUCATOR DEVELOP
PERFORMANCE TASK TO SUPPORT
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE AND
CIVICS LEARNING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE RIGHT THAT WILL LEAD TO
THE IDEA ACTUALLY THINK THERE
WERE A COUPLE MORE WITNESSES
THAN PLAN TODAY AND SINCE THE
PRESIDENT OF WE GET MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
OKAY THIS BE THE LAST ONE.
HE'S TRYING TO FOLLOW THE RULES
ARE SET BY OUR CHAIRMAN.
OF MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MONEY IF LET'S
FRANCIS AND I AM THE NATIONAL
CHAIRMAN OF THE NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN FOR THE CIVIC MISSION
SCHOOLS.
A COALITION OF OVER SIXTY
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO THE
PROPOSITION THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE. IN TERMS OF CIVIC LEARNING
THIS COUNTRY AND IN THE STATE.
OF ALSO A. NATIVE CALIFORNIAN
HAVING JUST RETURNED FROM
WASHINGTON DC OR FORTY YEAR
CAREER THERE AND NOW LIVE. IN EL
DORADO COUNTY.
I HAVE EXTENDED STATEMENT THAT
ALL SUBMIT FOR THE RECORD BUT I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TO
CRITICAL NEED TO DO MORE IN THE
AREA OF CIVIC LEARNING.
WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF POLLS AND
STUDIES IN WHAT NOT TO SHOW THIS
NEED AND I'M JUST GOING TO CITE
ONE.
AND THAT IS THE RESULTS FROM.
OF THE TWENTY FOURTEEN NATIONAL
ASSESSMENT OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRESS OF EIGHTH GRADERS.
WHICH FOUNDED IN THE AREA OF
CIVICS.
FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS ARE PERFORMED AT THE
BASIC LEVEL.
TWENTY TWO PERCENT WERE FOUND TO
BE PROFICIENT.
ONLY TWO PERCENT PERFORMED AT
THE ADVANCED LOCAL. THAT MEANS
THAT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS TESTED.
SCORED BELOW BASIC.
THEY SIMPLY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT OUR INSTITUTIONS AND
GOVERNMENT OR HISTORY OR
ANYTHING ELSE. AND THOSE ARE THE
VOTERS IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE. AND
THERE'S YOU KNOW NAY PER.
DOES NOT TO SEGREGATE TO STATE
AT THE STATE LEVEL SO WE HAVE NO
IDEA OF KNOWING HOW CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE DOING.
AND THIS BILL MOVES IN THE
DIRECTION OF MAKING THAT
POSSIBLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
THERE NOW I GUESS.
ALTUS MONEY FOR THIS SHOULD IS
DOWN.
JUST GIVE ME TO SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU. ANYBODY LIKES DOING
ME TO SUPPORT OF THIS. YEAR
SENATOR THE LA COUNTYOFFICE OF
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID GORDON THE US SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT IN.
IN STRONG SUPPORT NICER.
HEALING ONLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ADOPTED PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AND FRED JONES ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR THE SOCIAL STUDIES AND.
THANK VERY MUCH SIR.
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYBODY SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
ANYONE SPEAKING OPPOSITION.
CNN I WILL GO TO THE DíAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A MOVE BY.
IN A SECOND.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM A DíAS I
JUST HAVE ECONOMIST RICHER ON IN
YOUR CLOSING EFFETE.
OKAY. WELL ACTUALLY IT'S A.
IT'S IT'S PROBABLY A COMMENT AND
A QUESTION.
OKAY SO I'LL ASK IT TRIGGERED
LEAST SHARED. AND.
.
IT WHERE I'M GOING WITH THIS
COMMENT IS UNIT TESTING HELPS
IDENTIFY THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP BUT
ASSESSMENTS HELP CLOSE IT.
SO I HOPE THE DIRECTION WE'RE
GOING THIS IS A MORE ASSESSMENT
BASED APPROACH IN ONE Y. ME BY
THAT ASSESSMENTS CAN BE GIVEN
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
DIFFERENT STOPS ALONG THE YEAR
THEY BE GIVEN ON IN AUGUST YOU
KNOW WHEN THE SCHOOL YEAR STARTS
IN SEPTEMBER IN THE TEST THE
SUMMIT TESTS.
WHICH I WOULD ARGUE THAT'S BACK
LARGELY AS OF THIS POINT IS
GIVEN LATER MUCH LATER IN THE
YEAR. SO WHERE I HOPE WE'RE
GOING WITH THIS EFFORT AND MANY
OTHERS AND THE ASPECT.
IS THAT IT BECOMES AN ASSESSMENT
TOOL NOT JUST A TESTING.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU SAYING
THAT.
.
AND YOU PROBABLY KNOW BEST BEING
UNITS
TEACHERS ALSO.
THEY PERCENT.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK TO THAT THING
GOING ON HER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
WHICH LED TO CLOSE.
I'VE BEEN ES RENATO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL. I PUT ON MY SHIRT AND
I SAW THIS AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. AYE THE AYE
JONES SAWYER DONE.
WELL.
WEBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR BILL IS
OUT AND.
.
IS BEING PASSED OFF TO.
APPROPRIATIONS.
SHE AND ANOTHER ON THE
BACK MY GAVEL. AND LEAVE THE
ROOM